hi how are you Emily I feel like so busy
don't worry how are you good
ok so ok great ok
my first question do you think we find
our purpose
we're going back philosophical ah um I
think our purpose finds us I feel like
things come to me I I think one could
argue that I'm doing the behavior that
allows that to happen but but for some
reason I believe that you're chosen a
little bit and because I believe it a
little bit more in DNA than I think most
people like I'm gonna be a senior at sea
so I'm trying to figure out my big news
after graduation
if you don't exactly know what your
passion is and like a physical sense of
something you know like creating
business ideas or things like that like
I'm more like my passionate people so
yeah I mean look I think I think that
there's a lot of people that don't even
know that it's people like you know what
I mean yeah so I think you're ahead of
the game we're living a time right now
where so many people of your age think
that they have to have a business or
it's cool to have a business like there
was no [ __ ] 22 year old talking about
having a business 15 years ago so you
have to recognize that that's just a
conversation of the moment I'm gonna
give you a really good piece of advice
of this very short period of time be
binary about your decisions let me tell
you what I mean by that don't overthink
jumping into your first job and then
quit it the next day if it doesn't feel
right it's not a and all be all if if
the first one's not right nobody's gonna
give a [ __ ] if you've got four companies
on your resume first two years no place
you want to end up yeah well then if you
do you would stop thinking about this
completely yes
so either you get it or you don't
yeah so when you say I get that like I
want to actually have that conversation
because if you do get that you're about
to get really happy and real carefree if
you don't get that you need to keep
chipping away to believe it
it's [ __ ] life
yeah like nobody knows what the [ __ ]
gonna happen tomorrow so how do you and
I'm sorry it's already good how do you
deal with like with it by recognizing I
have no [ __ ] choice
right yeah like cuz that's actually life
like who the like zero people exist nope
that's what my every aspect you have to
you have to fit because I'm confident
yeah like I'm not scared because I know
I can handle anything you know and and I
know I can handle anything because I'm
grateful for everything I've got and I
never envy and want anything else I'm an
optimist like if something bad happens
tomorrow I would default into thinking
well I'm so grateful that I've had it
for this long yeah instead of like why
did it go away a hundred percent and you
need to chip away at that and you need
to realize what's practical not so great
I've met a lot of people like I like to
network I talk to people and like
everyone is just like you know if you
want to talk about whatever for 15
minutes in the conflict kitchen like
everyone is so willing to do that and
that's so refreshing and it's so it
makes you feel like just so much better
about your future because the more I
talk to people the more I hear that
everybody just had no idea what they
were doing
my age and it all works out 100% that so
reassuring that makes me happy makes me
happy thank you for that but that's
awesome so I really really appreciate
that you're welcome to advise yeah
awesome I'll see you soon I'm doing the
group chat with you guys soon so yeah
that's again
that's an October have a great weekend
take care